you got a little Euro Step when you hit
homers you're like expanding the culture
bringing culture to the game is that how
you show your love your passion like
what where did that come from all my
favorite players Griffey bonds canoe Jim
Edmonds and the guys that really like
admire their swings everybody really
hated the way that they acted on the
field when Griffey first came in no
nobody liked the way he played he was
pimping homers nobody liked this
changing the code he was changing the
culture right so like I love that bro
like I grew up loving that those guys
were my favorite players even though
like I would talk to like my coaches and
my coaches would be like oh he
disrespects the game and I would go and
like play in the Little League game and
do the same thing you know I mean like
that was about like oh Griffey pinned
the Homer like this I'm gonna try and do
it too like nobody ever liked me when I
was playing baseball like the other team
always hated me like college Scouts in
there Pro Scouts watching I didn't care
I flipped the ball from under here in a
showcase it didn't matter like I didn't
care about showing off my arm I just
cared about being flashy so